and my wife is pregnant yes that too
that's exciting Josh Peck on expecting
his first child with wife Paige O'Brian
while chatting with ET on the red carpet
at the premiere of a new Amazon Prime
Original Series Tom Clancy's Jack Ryan I
need to keep making money cuz I'm having
a baby the two broke the exciting news
last week instagramming this sweet pic
of Paige's tiny baby bump the couple
also tweeted a hilarious video cleverly
titled telling friends my wife is
pregnant
actually just decided a couple weeks ago
but all all credits due to my wife
because anytime I look cool it's because
of her
of course Josh's former grandfathered
co-star John Stamos recently had a baby
of his own and Peck says he's already
taught him a ton about fatherhood he's
done this incredible beautiful
transition into being a dad and I know
that he wanted to have a kid for so long
so to watch him sort of flourish in that
way it has been enjoyable and as Josh
and Paige prepare for the arrival of
their own little one do they have anyone
in mind as a Godfather maybe you never
know Stamos is a godfather
not that I'd want him looking out for my
kid for the rest of his life
you